is ready to proceed to the vote on the
draft resolution before it
please raise their hand
the result of the voting is as follows
the draft resolution received 15 votes
in favor
the draft resolution has been adopted
unanimously as resolution 26 27 of the
year 2022
the united states of america
thank you madam president
the united states would like to express
its appreciation to council members for
this mandate renewal
and for the important discussions that
brought us here
the 1718 committee panel of experts
continues to be indispensable in
investigating the dprk's unlawful
weapons program and sanctions evasion
efforts
despite the limitations of the covet 19
pandemic the panel has nevertheless
continued to effectively monitor the
implementation of these sanctions
we remain grateful to the panel for
their invaluable contributions to the
1718 regime
colleagues i have often repeated the
importance of effectively overseeing
implementation of the 1718 sanctions
regime in this chamber which is made
possible by the critical work of the
panel
this is particularly essential in light
of the dprk's escalatory provocations
since the beginning of the year
there's more that we could
and should do to empower the panel
and ensure their work can be best
leveraged by all member states to fully
implement the relevant security council
resolutions
although we were unable to come to
agreement on how to do this in the
resolution we voted on today i look
forward to collaborating with my fellow
council members and all member states
toward our shared objective of holding
the dprk accountable for its unlawful
behavior
i want to end by expressing the united
states concern over the report leakage a
concern i know many council members
share and i hope that all parties
protect the report until it is publicly
released moving forward
the united states also asked that the
panel deliver the incident report
requested by multiple council members on
the dprk's unlawful ballistic missile
launches earlier this year
i look forward to working with the
council to continue supporting the
panel's mandate and fully implementing
the international sanctions regime
addressing the dprk's unlawful wmd and
ballistic missile program thank you
madam president
thank
however at the same
triggering false speculation in the
media
media
about this
that it is necessary for the council to
raise the issue of legal reports and
confidentiality of information in this
year's resolution
and accordingly
[Music]
china's legislative concerns we're here
by register our deep discontent
has become a chronic problem
and if it is not taken seriously and
addressed in a timely manner it will
severely damage the credibility of that
and interfere with the normal
functioning
and will ultimately add to the
complexities to the castle's handling of
the dprk related issues
create a negative chain reaction among
other expert groups
in the council to pay greater attention
to these issues
in accordance with their mandate
in the country
and in the committee
and looks forward to the support of all
parties when the time comes
in the issue of the korean peninsula i
will give a full presentation of china's
position
of such incidents
federation and give the floor now to the
representative of norway
thank you president
first allow me to thank the united
states as penholder of the 1718
committee for facilitating the process
that led to the renewal of the mandate
of the 1718 committee's panel of experts
for one year
this process has given all council
members an opportunity to contribute and
we appreciate that consensus has been
reached on a technical rollover
i wish to express our great support and
appreciation for the panel's hard work
which provides the committee with
concrete findings and recommendations
the reports produced by the panel
continued to offer invaluable insights
and background information for both
committee members and un member states
president the numerous missile launches
over the last months reports from dprk
state media on the development of new
missiles technologies and the lack of an
international presence in the dprk due
to its self-imposed covet restriction
all shows that assessment from the panel
of experts are more crucial than ever we
therefore welcome the panel's assessment
and reporting and incidents of possible
non-compliance with relevant security
council resolutions also in the interim
periods between the submission of its
interim and final reports
i would also like to reiterate the
importance of the confidentiality of the
reports of the panel of experts
or related information before
publication
any leakage a confidential information
especially the panel's report before the
commission committee has had an
opportunity to consider and discuss it
only
diminishes the credibility of the work
of the committee and severely impacts
its effort to oversee the sanctioned
measures and address non compliance we
once again thank the council members for
the valuable effort to renew this
mandate and extend our sincere thanks to
the
entire panel of experts for their
continued work on this topic thank you
very
much
of norway
is
is
is
technology
thank you very much
madam president members of the council
the state news agency of the democratic
people's republic of korea
reported that dprk launched a new type
of intercontinental continental
ballistic missile
at approximately
34 p.m local time on 24 march
the missile so-called hwasong-17
was reportedly launched from sunan an
area north of pyongyang
it covered a range of 1090 kilometers
and reached an apogee of around 6200
kilometers
it made impact in the sea
within japan's exclusive economic zone
the last time the dprk conducted an icm
icbm test was on 29 november 2017.
madam president the secretary general
strongly condemns the dprk's latest icbm
launch
this is a flagrant breach of the dpkrk's
own
2018 moratorium and a clear violation of
relevant security council
resolutions this launch risk triggering
a significant escalation of tensions in
the region and beyond
the dprk has conducted 12 launches using
ballistic missile technology this year
alone
this is the fifth time the secretariat
has been asked to brief the council in
2022 in this connection
according to public statements by the
dprk
the launches involved among other things
a test of so-called hypersonic weapons
railway-borne missiles
an intermediate-range ballistic missile
and tests of systems related to the
development of so-called military
reconnaissance
satellites
it should be recalled that the council
in resolution 2397
reaffirmed its decisions that the dprk
shall not conduct any further launches
using ballistic missile technology
the dprk did not issue airspace or
maritime safety notifications for any of
these launches
the international civil aviation
organization has repeatedly informed the
dprk
that unannounced missile launches
represent a serious risk to
international civil aviation
icao has also called on the dprk to act
in accordance with the convention on
international civil aviation
madam president the dprk also appears to
be actively pursuing its nuclear program
on 7 march the director general of the
international atomic energy agency
reported that there were quote
ongoing indications consistent with the
operation of the five megawatt reactor
at the yang beyond site end quote
the iaea added that they continued to
observe construction activities at the
yangyang site including the construction
of an annex to the reported centrifuge
enrichment facility
the same day
satellite imagery analysis
indicated that there was renewed
activity at the punggye-ri nuclear test
site for the first time since pyongyang
announced its closure and dismantlement
in 2018.
in pursuing its nuclear capability and
ballistic missile programs the dprk is
defying the repeated demands of the
council to cease such activities
we have consistently conveyed these
concerns to the dprk
madam president the secretary general
reiterates the importance of addressing
humanitarian imperatives in the dprk
the united nations remains engaged and
stands ready along with its humanitarian
partners to assist people in need in the
dprk
whose vulnerability has likely increased
since the pandemic outbreak and border
closures in 2020
we reiterate our call
for the entry of international staff
including the u.n resident coordinator
and the unimpeded entry of humanitarian
supplies
to allow for a timely and effective
response
madam president the secretary general
affirms
reaffirms his commitment to working with
all parties for sustainable peace and
the complete and verifiable
denuclearization of the korean peninsula
he urges the dprk
to comply with the decisions of the
council
reset the course to dialogue and build
on previous diplomatic efforts
further the united nations welcomes the
regular contact and cooperation among
the key parties on the korean peninsula
we commend the parties for their
willingness to engage in dialogue with
the dprk without preconditions
madam president let me close by
reiterating that the unity of the
security council in this matter
is essential to ease tensions overcome
the diplomatic impasse and avoid a
negative action reaction cycle thank you
madam president
carlos thank you carlo for her
and i now give the floor to those
council lovers who wish to make
participants i give the floor to the
representative of the united states of
america
thank you again madam president and
thank you under secretary de carlo for
for your briefing
the united states along with albania
france ireland norway and the united
kingdom
call for today's open meeting on the
dprk
the first since 2017 because of the
urgency of the escalating situation
let me be crystal clear the united
states absolutely condemns the dprk
international intercontinental ballistic
missile launch on march 24th
this launch violated multiple security
council resolutions
it was an egregious and unprovoked
escalation
and it poses a threat to the global
proliferation regime and the entire
international community
this launch warrants
immediate and immediate response from
the council
this is the dprk's 13th ballistic
missile launch this year
the united states and allies assessed
that
two of these previous launches were also
of icbm systems
the dprk's long-range ballistic missile
system can threaten nearly every u.n
member state
although the dprk tried to mask recent
launches under the guise of supporting a
reconnaissance satellite the march 24
launch
demonstrates unequivocally
the dprk's intent to continue to advance
its long-range ballistic missile systems
you may have also seen meteor reports
that the dprk is reconstructing a
nuclear testing site that has been
closed
since 2018.
the imagery and the analysis are
alarming
so it is clear that the dprk has
escalated its provocations with impunity
while the council has remained silent
and it is clear that remaining silent
in the hope that the dbrk would
similarly show restraint
is a failed strategy
we must pivot to a successful one
the security council must speak publicly
and with one voice to condemn the dprk's
unlawful actions and encourage the dprk
to return to the negotiating table
the united states remains committed to a
diplomatic solution
we hope the dprk will accept our
repeated offers of dialogue
but we also cannot stand idly by in the
face of the dprk's repeated security
resolution
violations we have also heard recent
calls for sanctions relief for the dprk
but why should the security council
reward bad behavior
the dprk has broken its self-imposed
moratorium on launching icbms and has
repeatedly shown that it is more
interested in advancing its unlawful
weapons program than investing in the
welfare of its own people
this is not my opinion
and it's not a secret
the regime itself openly outlined this
strategy in the 2021 party congress to
develop increasingly sophisticated and
advanced wmd and ballistic missile
capabilities
offering sanctions relief without
substantive diplomatic progress would
only funnel more rev revenue to the
regime and accelerate the realization of
its wmd and ballistic weapons goals
it also sends the wrong message to other
wnd proliferators
that the security council will reward
them for repeatedly undermining the
non-proliferation regime
meanwhile the sanctions regime has
undeniably restricted the dprk's
unlawful weapons advancements
so now is not the time to end our
sanctions
now is the time to enforce them
the united states calls on all member
states to fully implement the existing
security council resolutions
and because of dprk's increasingly
dangerous provocations the united states
will be introducing a chapter 7 security
council resolution to update and
strengthen the sanctions regime
in security council resolution 2397
which we unanimously adopted the council
decided we would take further action in
the event of a dprk icbm launch
this is precisely what happened so now
is the time to take that action
and no matter what sanctions regimes
require regular updating and maintenance
to be effective
now is the time to make these critical
updates
so i call on all my fellow council
members to approach the
negotiations on a text constructively
toward our shared goal of
denuclearization
colleagues this isn't a bilateral issue
it's not a regional issue
it's an issue for all of us
the dprk's pursuit of weapons of mass
destruction and its ballistic missile
delivery system poses a threat to every
member of the global community
history especially recent history has
shown us that council silence
and sanctions relief
does not work
instead we must come together
just like we did in 2016 and 2017 to
send an unequivocal message to the dprk
that the security council and
international community will not ignore
dprk
case flagrant violations of security
council resolutions and its willful
disregard for regional and global
stability
let us act now
before the dprk escalates further to
send the message that the security
council will not waver in its
responsibility to protect the world from
weapons of mass destruction and maintain
international peace and security thank
you madam president
i thank the president of the united
states for the statement i now get
thank you madam president
i thank you decala for her update
we are sad that it confirms our
assessment
the pyongyang regime is continuously
stubbornly unilaterally and dangerously
escalating tensions in the region
threatening its neighbors
snubbing the security council and
violating the council's resolution
this is intolerable
this is the 13th missile launch this
year
in the very same pattern of defiance
in a previous meeting we asked
is there a threshold of defiance
of content of this body before we come
together and speak with young voice
dprk might think that the attention of
the council is elsewhere
they are mistaken
we will condemn their reckless actions
and we will not let this or any of their
provocations go unnoticed
the defying attitude and the renegade
acts by the pyongyang regime must be met
with the united and resolved council on
an open and determined response
dprk must be told in clear terms that
they cannot defy the international
community and they cannot disrespect
security council resolutions
resolutions are not to be contemplated
they are to be implemented
this is why albania joined others in
requesting this public meeting today
the council cannot continue to meet
behind doors it has shown patience
but it has been met with dprk's
indifference
therefore the regime must know that we
will not accept such behavior and that
it will not be held and that it will be
held accountable for such flagrant
breaches of international law
dear colleagues
failure of the council to denounce such
unlawful acts will only serve to
encourage the regime in pyongyang to
continue to blackmail its neighbors
threaten the region and endanger the
wilder world
inaction is tantamount to tacit approval
as we have said before it's a license to
do more of the same
this new and latest launch is a new
level of provocation
it represents another and repeated
breach of its self-announced moratorium
of 2018.
albania strongly condemn such
provocative acts and aggressive actions
we call on the regime to stop return to
the negotiation table
urgently and without preconditions
dear colleagues we just adopted the
resolution on the mandate renewal of
panel experts the dprk repeated missile
launches require a comprehensive and
timely analysis from the panel of
experts an incidence report of any
breach of united
nations security council resolutions by
the regime
we look forward to working with the
panel in this regard
while the regime is investing millions
in research into their ballistic
programs
its population continues to starve
isolated from the world keeping its
people undereducated inflicting untold
poverty
pain and suffering upon women men and
children
in the whole country
the regime needs to also be held
accountable for its mistreatment of the
population for human rights violations
slavery and economic starvation
the population needs food
the regime is giving them weapons
weapons that go higher faster
and further
starving the population and threatening
the region
but make no mistake missiles will not
make north korea any stronger any better
they will rather make it more isolated
and poorer
as it is the case
unfortunately regulatively
the catastrophic humanitarian situation
will not resolve by itself
pyongyang regime must allow an impeded
entry of humanitarian assistance in the
country which requires unfettered access
for international staff including the
resident coordinator
it is high time for the dprk to return
to the table of negotiations for an
unconditional meaningful dialogue under
diplomacy not provocations
we encourage all members of this council
to show unity this means issuing common
simple factual press elements
our goal is and must remain a complete
comprehensive reversible and verifiable
declaration of the entire korean
peninsula
and now you're the fourth representative
of ireland
thank you madam president and thank you
to usg de carlo for her
useful briefing
madam president ireland condemns
yesterday's launch of an
intercontinental ballistic missile by
the dprk
we are gravely concerned by the ongoing
intensive and escalatory series of
launches by the dprk since the end of
last year in violation of security
council resolutions
this icbm launch represents a serious
escalation in the continuing
destabilizing actions by the dprk
it is designed to raise tensions
threatening the peace and stability of
the korean peninsula and the wider
region
as well as to undermine the global
non-proliferation architecture
it is a further flagrant
challenge to the serious concerns of the
international community
and to the authority of this council
madam president these launches are all
the more worrisome given the dprk's
continuing nuclear activities
the council has been silent too long
it must speak now with a clear
strong and unified voice
to make clear to the dprk that it cannot
continue down this path without
repercussions
we therefore strongly support a council
press statement on this matter
we must be clear
that further ballistic missile tests or
a nuclear test are utterly unacceptable
we must together
urge the dprk to end its destabilizing
actions
we must together press the dprk to take
up the good faith offer of talks by the
united states and south korea without
preconditions
and we must together hold the dprk to
its obligations to abandon its ballistic
missile program and its nuclear and
other wmg programs in a complete
verifiable and irreversible manner
the dprk should also heed the council's
long-standing calls to resume its
obligations under the mpt and iaea
safeguards and to sign and ratify the
comprehensive nuclear test ban treaty
madam president this council has been
clear in resolution 23 97
that it has a responsibility to act in
response to an icbm launch
and we will need to look at appropriate
actions
we must stem the sophisticated
sanctions of asian efforts by the dprk
which fund and assist procurement for
the dprk's illegal problems
this council's resolutions including
those relating to the 1718 sanctions
regime must be fully and effectively
enforced
the panel of experts has repeatedly with
detailed evidence set out important
recommendations
including on designations of the vessels
and entities involved
and on the need to update relevant
control lists
we must act urgently on these
recommendations
finally madam president
we urge
we again urge the dprk to respond to the
concerns and offers of assistance from
the international community regarding
the dire humanitarian situation in the
country
we urge the dprk to allow access for the
un and other humanitarian actors to
assess needs and provide appropriate
assistance
the dprk has over the past 30 or 30
years
prioritized its illegal military
programs over the livelihoods
well-being
and rights of its own citizens with
disastrous consequences for its own
people it is clear that there must be a
diplomatic and peaceful resolution to
the issues on the korean peninsula
unfortunately it appears that the dprk
alone does not understand this
the dprk must respond concretely and
credibly to the concerns of the
international community
it will then find this council in a
position to reciprocate with concrete
measures
it is and it has always been in the
dprk's hands thank you madam president
on the 24th
is
doing
resolution
suggesting that there is
and more
sanctions
or dialogue
the
[Music]
and now with the florida representative
of norway
thank you president and uh thanks to
usg rosemary de carlo for your brief
norway strongly condemns the launch of
an intercontinental ballistic missile by
the dprk on 24 march
the continued development of nuclear
weapons and ballistic missiles by the
dprk is a direct threat to regional and
international peace and security and is
in violation of several u.n security
council resolutions
we deeply regret that this latest launch
along with a test on 27 february and 5th
march leaves no doubt that the dprk has
ended its moratorium on such tests
it also falls into a pattern of numerous
missile tests over the past months
including a variety of missiles and
technologies
these are cause for great concern
we continue to stress that the
government of the dprk must comply fully
with its international obligation
reverse its course and withdrawing the
international non-proliferation regime
through the npt and iaea safeguards
the behavior and threats from the dprk
have reached a new magnitude
and we are concerned that the dprk will
continue to escalate its illegal
activities
previous reports by the panel of experts
show that dprk's high level of
commitment to sustaining and further
developing
developing its wmd programs
the current path is not only a threat to
international peace and security but it
also aggravates an already deteriorating
economic humanitarian and human rights
situation within the country the dprk's
desire to develop nuclear capacities and
missile system does not contribute to
the future of the north korean people it
keeps them stuck in the past
we are profoundly sad to see the
government continue to channel its
resources to weapons development
instead of delivering basic services to
its own people
we call on the dprk to end itself in
post blockade and allow the un its
resident coordinator another
international organization to re-enter
and resume their humanitarian work
and we call on north korea to respond to
repeated offers of dialogue and to take
concrete steps to a burden its wmd and
ballistic missile programs in a complete
verifiable and in irreversible manner
until concrete steps are taken the
sanctions measure imposed by this
council must remain in force and be
fully implemented by all states thank
you
i thank representative of norway for our
statements i now report to the president
thank you madam president and i join
others in thanking under secretary de
carlo for her briefing
the uk condemns the test of an
intercontinental ballistic missile by
north korea on the 24th of march
as well as tests of new icbm
capabilities on the 27th of february and
the 5th of march
this year alone
13 ballistic missiles have been launched
across 10 sets of tests
each a violation of the security council
resolutions
we're deeply concerned by the increased
tempo of these launches and the growing
capability they represent
let there be no doubt
the clear threat that north korea poses
to international security is
increasing these violations of security
council resolutions
should be met with a firm and united
response from this council
the last time north korea launched icbms
in 2017
the council responded decisively
by adopting resolution 2371
we look to this council to display the
same unity and resolve to protect the
safety of this and future generations
as it displayed then
and we look forward to constructive
discussions on further measures proposed
by the usa
we should urgently therefore consider
further steps that this council can take
including updated and targeted sanctions
to disrupt north korea's unlawful
testing and illicit
proliferation we call on all member
states
to implement fully the security
council's resolutions
and enforce sanctions unanimously
adopted
in order to limit north korea's illicit
nuclear and ballistic missile programs
as the north korean government continues
to pour resources into weapons programs
the humanitarian situation in the
country
may be worsening
the uk is clear
that the council's measures against
these illicit weapons programs including
sanctions
are not targeted at the north korean
people we fully support the delivery of
humanitarian support
to the most vulnerable in north korean
society
we call upon north korea
to allow un humanitarian workers
to carry out an independent needs
assessment
and to allow aid to flow freely into the
country
we urge north korea to refrain from
further provocations
engage meaningfully with the us in
dialogue
and abandon all of its nuclear weapons
and existing nuclear programs in a
complete
verifiable and irreversible manner
i thank you madam president
thank you representatives
thank you
madam president
thank you for convening this meeting
today
we thank usg de carlo for her briefing
we welcome the participation of japan
and the republic of korea in today's
meeting as well
we have noted the concerns expressed by
countries in the region
on the dprk's launch of an
intercontinental ballistic missile
india deplores the launch of an icbm by
the dprk
this is a violation of the resolutions
of the u.n security council relating to
the dprk
it affects peace and security of the
region and beyond
further the launch contravenes dprk's
own self-declared moratorium against the
launch of icbms and goes against the
objective of the denuclearization of the
korean peninsula which has been endorsed
by the dprk itself
we call for full implementation of the
u.n security council resolutions related
to the dprk
this council has met several times since
the beginning of the year to discuss the
series of missile launches by the dprk
in this context we would like to recall
our request to the panel of experts
under the
1718 committee for incident reports on
these launches in the context of the
relevant u.n security council
resolutions
we hope that the panel will come out
with its reports soon
india also believes that there is a
pressing need to address the
proliferation of nuclear and missile
technologies related to the dprk in our
region
these linkages
have an adverse impact on the peace and
security in the region including on
india
india supports dialogue to resolve the
issue in the korean peninsula
madam president india is sensitive to
the humanitarian situation in the dprk
and we had granted humanitarian
assistance for million dollars for the
people of the dprk in the form of
anti-tuberculosis medicines rooted
through the who
we also note that the 1718 sanctions
committee has been extending approvals
for the humanitarian assistance as and
when they are received
finally india reiterates its continued
support to denuclearization towards
peace and security in the korean
peninsula i thank you
i thank the representative of india for
the statement i now give the floor to
the representative of china
she's here
thank you madam president
madam president
has long been an important item on the
council's agenda over the past few years
we have witnessed uh
whereby they reached important consensus
on improving their bilateral relations
advancing the peninsula's
denuclearization process it was on that
basis that the dprk
pledged a moratorium a nuclear test and
test launches of icbms which marked a
major step forward towards the
peninsula's denuclearization however so
early evening are they are unintended as
from early 2021 and in particular
starting
causing tensions to rise tensions being
the counterpoint
as the peninsula's next door neighbors
china has been consistent in advocating
and promoting the peninsula's peace and
stability his denuclearization and the
approach of seeking a solution through
dialogue and consultation that we were
hoping the us would actively pursue
the us and the educator will actually
pursue dialogue and engagement in search
of an effective solution to manage and
settle their differences
failed to take tangible practical
actions in response to the gpi to
justify concerns other than speaking
about quote unquote talks without
preconditions now that the dprk has
announced the ictm test which china is
concerned about how things are evolving
right now under the current
circumstances we call on the party's
concern to stay calm exercise restraint
stay on the right track of dialogue and
consultation and avoid taking any action
that may exacerbate the tensions and
lead to misjudgments
direct parties to the peninsula issue
namely the united states and the dprk
should re-engage in direct talks
it is right and proper for the u.s side
to show its goodwill take actions that
are of practical relevance and work
harder to stabilize the situation build
mutual trust
and relaunch dialogue
madam president
given the evolving situation before when
the international community should
resort
and play a positive constructive role in
bringing about a political solution to
the peninsula issue
we should do all we can to maintain the
peninsula's peace and stability which
must be treasured right now all is not
quite on the international front no
party should take any action that would
lead to greater tensions and the
peninsula cannot afford the risk from
any dramatic change much less a reversal
of the situation with dire consequences
what needs to happen now as a matter of
urgency
as a matter of urgency is for the
parties concerned to actively see a
political way out of the impasse on the
basis of existing understandings in the
light of the latest developments china
calls on the parties to put the greatest
good of peace and stability
speak and act with caution pursue
dialogue and consultation take the dual
track approach guided by the principle
of moving forward in phases with
synchronized steps and work tirelessly
to denuclearize the peninsula and to
build peace mechanisms
second the dprk's justified concerns
must be addressed the particular
has remained unresolved for decades
there's a reason why the situation has
come to where it is today
is that the external security threat to
the dprk have persisted for decades and
their justified security concerns have
remained unaddressed throughout the
process
the dpi can make it clear and i quote
following the dpi
the u.s side instead of honoring its
promise to stop joint military exercises
with the rok went ahead and deployed his
strategic nuclear weapons in the
surrounding areas of the korean
peninsula putting the dpi security and
serious jeopardy
those pronouncements by the dprk or to
be taken seriously by the parties
concerned and this council or to
consider how to accommodate the dprk's
justified security concerns in keeping
with the principle of indivisible
security
the us and the dpik must resume direct
talks as soon as possible facts have
spoken time and again that dialogue and
diplomacy upfront is the only way to
avert a crisis
allowing the situation to go down the
slippery slope is not in anyone's
interest
starting in 2018 there was a major
positive turnaround in the peninsula
situation
however a range of steps taken by the
dprk were not duly reciprocated this is
not consistent with the principle of
action for action that forms part of
their consensus yes it also shows up
or the office of dialogue for what they
are mere jingles
where things are headed going forward
depends to a large extent what the u.s
is going to do are they going to come up
with concrete actions that can actually
solve problems or are they going to
continue using the peninsula issue
that's a bargaining chip in their
geopolitical strategy
the u.s must not continue to brush aside
justified demands it should offer an
attractive proposal to pave the way
for early resumed
it is dialogue
to interpret and implement the security
council resolutions concerning dprk in a
comprehensive manner
these resolutions should be implemented
comprehensively completely and
accurately advancing a critical solution
and
effective implementation of certain
provisions vary
the party's concern should take this
issue seriously and take practical
actions rather than put one-sided
emphasis on the sanctions provisions
this council should play a constructive
role when it comes to the
issue they should not stress their need
for sanctions and pressurization and
exclusion of other considerations the
china russia draft resolution on the
dprk serves one purpose also one purpose
only that is to ease the humanitarian
and likelihood applied in the dprk
create an enabling atmosphere for
greater trust between parties with a
view to dialogue and thereby inject an
impetus into the political solutions of
the peninsula
draft is just valid we encourage all
parties to give it positive
consideration and supported
and
support
madam president it is in the common
interest of all countries the
safeguarding international nuclear
non-proliferation regime
a constructive role in promoting the
resolution of the hot button
non-proliferation issues and maintaining
regional peace and stability i thank you
madam president
artil kalimalan
a
yesterday on the 24th
missiles
of missiles
technological capacity
organisms
thank you madame
i thank mexico and i give the for the
ghana thank you very much madame
president for giving me the floor and
also for convening this open meeting
i would also like to thank usg rosemary
dicarlo for her briefing to the council
and welcome the representatives of japan
and the republic of korea to the meeting
we are meeting today under heavy clouds
of escalating tensions on the korean
peninsula
and the wider northeast
asia region
these tensions have been located not
only by the dprk's launch of the hong
song 17
ballistic missile yesterday
but also by its 11 previous launches of
ballistic missiles this year alone
the fact that this council has agreed to
meet an open session after six close
consultations since the beginning of
this year
shows the grave concern that the
international community has over the
situation
the present missile launch represents an
end
represents an end to dprk self-imposed
moratorium on icbm tests
and the first long-range icbm test since
2017.
the implications of this new development
for international peace and security
including for the dprk's immediate
neighbors are grave
and we must all acknowledge that
equally warring is the fact that the
launch was carried out without regard to
aviation and maritime safety
ghana is therefore gravely concerned
about this current launch which is in
blatant violation of the dprk's
international obligations
has expressed the multiple united
nations security council resolutions
the reported intention of the dprk to
develop a nuclear war deterrent
in preparation for a long-standing
confrontation with another member states
goes contrary
to its obligations under the nuclear
nonproliferation treaty and the regime
and the principles of the charter of the
united nations which i'm enjoying all
member states to be peace loving
madame preston the actions of the dprk
have heightened contentions on the
korean peninsula
at a time when international communities
focus on finding a pathway for dialogue
and diplomacy
to address the origin developments in
ukraine and its consequences
in this regard we urge the dprk to
refrain from further missile test
launches
and to take the urgent unnecessary steps
to ease tensions in the region
we also reiterate our call on the dprk
to adhere to the relevant security
council resolutions
the world can all afford to have
multiple crises at this time
when we are still grappling with the
many deaths on both sides of the wall in
ukraine
the displacement of more than 10 million
people from that country
and the transmission of the shocks of
food and energy secreted across several
parts of the world with an associated
rise in cost of living
therefore retreat is called for the
resumption of constructive and credible
dialogue between the relevant parties
and the dprk
to find an enduring comprehensive and
peaceful solution to the issues on the
korean peninsula
and in a manner that recognizes the
original and guruba security concerns
as well as those of the parties
in this regard we encourage the u.s to
sustain its offer of dialogue with the
dprk evaporate conditions
and urged the dprk to accept the offer
in good faith in support of the cause
for peace
madam president it is worth noting that
while tensions on the korean peninsula
are high
the humanitarian situation and the dprk
continues to be dire
ghana commends the council and the ice
1718 committee for his proactive
approach in addressing the humanitarian
situation the dprk
within the framework of exemptions in
the existing sanctions regime
and calls on the dprk to streamline its
internal processes to enable the much
needed medical and other humanitarian
supplies
to reach the people of the dprk
we also urge the dprk to allow the u.n
humanitarian agencies back into the
country
they support efforts by the u.n system
to re-establish the banking channel
within the dprk
we hope that this council and other
relevant
parties will be able to act in a manner
that preserves the peace while at the
same time ensuring
that the humanitarian needs of the
people of the dprk are addressed i thank
you very much for your attention
i thank ghana i give the floor to the
representative of kenya
thank you madam president
i thank under secretary general rosemary
dicarlo for a briefing
and welcome the participation of the
republic of korea
and japan
madame president
kenya is gravely concerned
by the latest intercontinental ballistic
missile test launch
by the democratic people's republic of
korea
in clear violation of the relevant
security council resolutions
this 13th test
launched since the beginning of the year
clearly demonstrates an escalation of
the situation
in the korean peninsula
indeed
the prospects
over assumption
in the testing of nuclear weapons
are regrettably increasing by the day
moreover
the launches carried out without
notification
to the relevant maritime and aviation
regulatory bodies
pose a serious threat
to maritime and air safety
the successive provocative acts are
driving the region into an arms race
with attendant destabilization effects
and great implications for global peace
and security
with a prevailing security situation
already posing syrian socio-economic and
security challenges
particularly in developing countries
the international community
can ill afford another crisis
regrettably
this escalation
of armaments is also dividing resources
away from the mike needed
social protection and development for
the people of the tprk
kenya calls on the dprk to hold any
further test launches and recommit
to the non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons
treaty iaea safety guards
and the relevant resolutions of the
security council
we reiterate
that the only path acceptable to the
international community
is genuine dialogue without
preconditions
there's dialogue that considers the
interests and perceptions of threats of
all parties in the region
in this regard
kenya urges the international community
to help restart diplomatic efforts
to find a lasting solution to the threat
in the korean peninsula for the sake of
global security
madam president
amidst this development
we call upon all parties concerned
to spare a thought
for the humanitarian flight plight
of approximately 11 million dprk
citizens who are in need both sides
have a responsibility
to ensure that any actions they take do
not exacerbate the suffering of the
people
but it is the dprk to demonstrate
commitment in this regard
by seizing its ballistic missile program
i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
their statement i now give the floor to
the representative of gabon merci madam
the president thank you merci madame
korea yesterday
commerce
threat
in 2017
uh
situations points to a uh an arms race
manufactured
to be used
to contribute to peace
and also in the face of the extreme
suffering of the civilian population in
the dprk
my country calls on the various parties
to engage in dialogue yeah
and
to focus on diplomatic
thank you very much
is
is
depending
north korea
which for many years
the further strengthening of sanctions
against
is
such as the association of the united
states
lasting results
to them
autonomous secondary sanctions against
dprk and other states should have been
introduced by washington and its allies
going above
but also
17 18 sanctions
in this connection we call on everyone
to exercise restraint and in
practice that have already been achieved
negotiations
[Music]
is what we've seen in recent months
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for their statement i
give the floor to brazil
thank you very much madam president
and let me
thank usg rosemary de carlo for once
again coming to brief the council on
this file
brazil strongly condemns the launch of
an intercontinental ballistic missile
by the dprk
this is a flagrant violation of multiple
security council resolutions
and a clear breach of dprk's own
moratorium on icbm launches
in january north korea broke the record
for most launches in a single month
now
they appear to have broken yet another
ominous record
as this seems to be the longest reaching
missile ever launched by pyongyang
the pattern of escalation is
self-evident
first multiple short-range ballistic
missile launches
then
intermediate range artifacts
a few weeks ago we witnessed alleged
launches of reconnaissance satellites
which were rehearsals for this launch
furthermore
it is the responsibility of this council
to avoid any risks of nuclear testing in
violation of its resolutions and
international treaties
this issue becomes all the more pressing
at the time when different countries
emphasize the relevance of nuclear
weapons in their defense doctrines and
deter strategies
madam president
the security council must work
tirelessly and transparently
in order to pave the way for the
de-escalation of tensions and for
sustainable solution
to this matter
it is our common responsibility
to halt any further escalation
the council should be proactive and
point in the direction of dialogue and
effective negotiations
we call upon the key actors in the
region to redouble efforts to engage
with pyongyang
with a view to bringing the dprk
back to the negotiating table
this council should stand ready to
support such a course of action
in the same brain
we cannot condone inaction on the issue
of dprk's nuclear program
we must strive to find a platform for
dialogue to push forward the realization
of a transparent verifiable and
irreversible denuclearization
of the korean peninsula
we avail ourselves of this opportunity
to once again call upon the dprk
to review its nuclear status
join the non-proliferation
non-proliferation treaty as a
non-nuclear weapon state and exceed to
the comprehensive nuclear test ban
treaty without delay i thank you
thank you representative
since last september
has launched 13 ballistic missiles since
the beginning of this year alone
including the recent test of an
intercontinental ballistic missile to
the accordingly
in the strongest terms these missile
tests
constitute
a flagrant violation of international
law and the relevant security council
resolutions
we also support the statement issued by
the un secretary general yesterday
regarding the recent escalation by dprk
while we express our deep concern over
the continued escalation by gprk
in the absence of deterrent measures by
the security council for those
violations we stress the importance of
the council's unity in responding to
this dangerous escalation which we
repeat undermines regional security on
the korean peninsula and affects
international security and stability
my country reiterates the importance of
pursuing peaceful solutions and giving
priority to the
diplomatic endeavors to avoid further
escalation in this regard we commend the
diplomatic efforts to resume dialogue
and we strongly urge the democratic
people's republic of korea to respond
positively to these endeavors and return
to the negotiating table
we also emphasize the importance that in
this critical situation
the key parties must find a common
formula to define an acceptable
framework for moving forward
while the decision makers and dprk
continue to devote the limited resources
of their country towards developing
nuclear and societal capabilities the
people in dprk continue to suffer from
the difficult humanitarian situation
caused largely by their country's
policies
alleviate the growing human suffering
by providing basic needs and necessities
and by cooperating with the united
nations to allow u.n humanitarian
workers to return to the dprk and carry
out their humanitarian work
my country reiterates that compliance
and full implementation of security
council resolutions by the member states
remains an essential pillar for
maintaining international peace and
security
cooperation with members of the security
council to address regional and
international proliferation threats
also understands the concerns related to
the development in supply of ballistic
missiles and their role in undermining
regional security the council should be
able to address those concerns thank you
i resume my function as president of the
council
the representative of the united states
of america
thank you madam president
some of our colleagues are trying to
frame this as a usdprk
problem
this is a threat that impacts all of us
and it is our collective responsibility
to respond
in terms of the humanitarian impact of
sanctions the experts have repeatedly
told us that the number one barrier to
sending humanitarian assistance into the
dprk is the dprk's self-imposed border
closures not international sanctions as
some of our colleagues have alleged
the united states remains committed
to addressing the humanitarian situation
in dprk which is why we have offered
to discuss these issues with the dprk
directly but have yet to receive a
response
we have also continued to support the
1718
committee swift processing of sanctions
exemptions to aid organizations and it
is why we are now working closely with
the un secretariat to establish a
reliable banking channel
we call on dprk to commit to the
well-being of its own people by
respecting human rights defunding its
unlawful wmd and ballistic missile
program and prioritizing the needs of
vulnerable north koreans
as for the draft resolution that china
and russia have proposed
is predicated on their assessment that
dprk is showing goodwill through a
moratorium as understood by the prc in
russia on irb bms and icbms and nuclear
tests
in addition to its january 30 rbm launch
the b
dprk has now ignored its own moratorium
on icbm tests three times on february
27th on march 5th
march 24th icbm launches
in light of these escalating
provocations and a return to testing
long-range systems the purported impetus
for the resolution is no longer valid we
need quickly to return to strengthening
the 1718 sanctions regimes
not considering sanction relief
and finally
on august although i do not want to
stray from the serious matter at hand i
do want to correct the erroneous claims
about august
the august initiative is to provide
conventionally armed nuclear powered
submarines to australia it does not
include nuclear armed submarines the npt
does not
prohibit
naval nuclear propel propulsion and
australia does not and will not seek
nuclear weapons consistent with its npt
obligations as a non-nuclear weapon
state
we take our npt commitments very
seriously which also drives our strong
support for the complete
denuclearization of the korean peninsula
thank you madam president
i thank you for
the floor is yours
thank you madam president
as we've discussed north korea's illegal
nuclear and ballistic missile programs
are in violation
of numerous security council resolutions
the trilateral cooperation between
australia
the us and the uk
will be fully consistent
with the three parties respective
non-proliferation obligations
and will be pursued in a manner that
preserves the integrity of the
non-proliferation regime
we remain fully committed
to peace
stability and prosperity in the
indo-pacific and worldwide i thank you
madam president
of korea
madam president
let me begin by thanking you for
convening today's emergency meeting of
the security council
i appreciate this opportunity to
participate
in the council's discussions
to address the dprk's intercontinental
ballistic missile launch
on march 24th
i also thank
usg rosemary de carlo for her briefing
madam president
the republic of korea condemns
in the strongest terms
the dprk's icbm launch
which
constitutes a flagrant violation of
multiple security council resolutions
it poses a serious threat
to the korean peninsula
the region
and
the international community and also
is a significant threat
to the global
non-proliferation regime
this launch means
that the dprk has reneged on its own
commitment
to a moratorium on icbm tests
that it had announced in april
2018
we welcomed the secretary general's
strong statement yesterday
and look forward to a firm and united
response by the security council
my delegation also
expresses its support
towards the u.s initiative to pursue a
new resolution in response to the dprk's
icbm launch
and calls on
other members of the council
to join in this effort
despite the international communities
repeated calls
for de-escalation
and dialogue the dprk
has continued its
provocative activities
in the last couple
of
months as evidenced through
countless ballistic missile launches
reports on dprk's movement
to restore its nuclear test site
and its ongoing nuclear related
activities are all deeply
concerning
they must stop immediately
madame president
throughout the past few years my
government has spared no effort to
restart dialogue with the north
to seek progress towards complete
denuclearization
and lasting peace on the korean
peninsula
we offer to hold dialogue
at the time place
and format that north korea prefers
my government has also expressed
his willingness to support the north
in responding to the global pandemic
regrettably all of these sincere efforts
were met with not only a cold silence
but also
with continued provocations
let me be clear
no one harbors any hostile policy
towards pyongyang
nor
is there any reason to do so
we strongly urge
the dprk
to refrain from further provocations
fulfill its obligations under the
relevant u.n security council
resolutions
and engage in meaningful dialogue with
the republic of korea and the united
states
toward
denuclearization and lasting peace on
the korean peninsula
we also call for all member states
to fully implement
relevant security council resolutions
and also
continue to support a peaceful and
diplomatic solution on the korean
peninsula
madam president
my government firmly believes
that dialogue and cooperation is the
only possible way forward
regardless of the hurdles we face
our commitment to improving inter-korean
relations
remains
unchanged
the door for dialogue
still remains open
we strongly urge the dprk to choose the
path of engagement and cooperation
instead of confrontation and escalation
the republic of korea
along with the international community
stands ready to work
constructively with the dprk
to make a better future for all of us
if
the dprk is willing to do so
as well i thank you madam president
i thank the representative of the
republic of korea for history
to the representative of japan
thank you madam president i also thank
miss rosemary dicaro for her briefing
madame president
yesterday
north korea launched an icbm-class
ballistic missile
which flew an estimated 100 kilometers
with an apogee of an estimated three six
thousand kilometers the longest reach of
any north korean launch to date
it impacted in the japanese exclusive
economic zone just
150 kilometers from japanese soil
japan strongly condemns this dangerous
and destabilizing act
it endangered vessels in our eez
and exposed aircraft in the surrounding
area to great safety risk
it poses an imminent and grave threat to
japan's
security
this is yet another serious violation of
multiple resolutions
adopted unanimously by this council
it increases proliferation risks
in every corner of the world and
threatens international peace and
security
madam president this is a clear
escalation
we need concrete and immediate action by
this council let me make three points
first the latest launch is the first
full-scale icbm launch since november
2017
japan was seated in this chamber at that
time
and
recalls
that that event led to the subsequent
adoption of security council resolution
2397
this resolution stipulates that
if the dprk conducts
a launch of a ballistic missile
a ballistic missile system
capable of reaching intercontinental
range
the council will take action
to restrict further the export to the
dprk of petroleum
i urge the council to follow up and do
what it already agreed to do
in this regard i welcome the us
initiative to introduce a new resolution
second
each of north korea's repeated missile
launches must not be viewed in isolation
they are part of its reinvigorated
nuclear and missile programs
north korea has publicly declared that
it intends to acquire various weapons
including tactical nuclear weapons
these willful and repeated violations of
council resolutions are partly a result
of the long
regrettable silence of the council this
should end now
third
this takes place
when the world is struggling to restore
peace in ukraine and save many innocent
civilian lives there
we must not allow north korea to take
advantage of this situation and further
develop its prohibited capacity
capability
madam president
the council has repeatedly made clear
that it is necessary to realize the
dismantlement of all of north korea's
weapons of mass destruction and
ballistic mis missiles of all ranges in
a complete verifiable and
irreversible manner in accordance with
relevant council resolutions
and these resolutions are not only about
what north korea needs to do but also
what we
the other member states
are obliged to do
japan strongly urges all member states
to fully implement relevant u.n security
council resolutions
it is not time for easing sanctions at
all
in conclusion
japan expects that the council will
fulfill its responsibility
by swiftly taking united action
japan will continue to work closely with
council members and all other member
states
to reach a comprehensive solution to the
problems related to north korea i thank
you
i thank the representative of japan for
his statement
i would kindly ask all observers to
promptly exit the chamber directly upon
the adjournment of this meeting
the meeting is adjourned
you